[Music]
what up everybody how you livin how you
feeling how you doing is the LEF koe man
and we are gonna have a really awesome
conversation with a quarterback former
quarterback from the NFL Darius Butler
saw his ass on get up the last few days
but we had him in here drafted in the
second round by the New England Patriots
gets drafted the same year that Tom
Brady is battling back from that injury
that ACL tear the season before he was
went to Carolina for the first year of
Cam Newton went to Indianapolis for the
first year of Andrew Luck and then
stayed with the Colts for five years but
just a good conversation covering
anything from what it was like what it's
like for Bill Belichick to release you
what it's like to be released and think
oh my gosh maybe it's over what it was
like for Cam Newton dealing with Steve
Smith his rookie year just a very
interesting conversation and then we
talked a little bit more about what to
expect this year the team's he's high on
the teams he's low on all of that will
be happening in a minute again I'm gonna
try and do this so there's less
commercials touring the interview but I
also want to give you an update on the
LF GL now let's [ __ ] go league last
year we had 396 competitors I believe it
boiled down to 28 different leagues
William Ezell is going to be the
Commissioner this year taking it over
from meatloaf Henry we did the cutoff at
Tuesday at 5 o'clock and I did get some
tweets and stuff afterwards that said oh
no I'm just seeing this and I hate to do
this to you but we can't because we have
to have rules or else what is society
and the other reason is because we have
a crapload of people the amount of
people that signed up this year again
last year was 396 1164 that is 97 12
team conferences
holy crap
so now there's that realization where I
went from oh this is so much fun - how
are we going to do this so let me just
explain this to you guys if you
mentioned on the sheet that you want to
be a commissioner you probably have
received an email from ezel please
respond seventy six of you have already
said you're willing have already
responded and said you're you're
definitely down to be a commissioner I
think a hundred and forty of you overall
said you'd be down to be a commissioner
so please respond to the email from now
on I'm not talking about this on the
podcast Ezell's gonna handle it but I'm
also gonna say this I am thinking of
leaning towards the sleeper app to do
the fantasy league now Yahoo not ESPN
the sleeper app it's what the fantasy
footballers are using it's very user
friendly I have already downloaded the
app it it seems super easy if you
haven't received an email confirmation
yet do not be worried we haven't sent
that out but sleeper apparently is gonna
make it possible for ezel to be the
active Commissioner for all ninety seven
leagues none of the other games really
allow us to do that and I think it's
gonna be tough
some people have reached out and said
hey August 22nd works but if you're
trying to do eight o'clock Eastern
that's three o'clock in England Ezell's
gonna try and find a way to communicate
with everybody that if you are overseas
maybe we do international leagues in
which you guys can have your drafts and
around whatever time you want it to be
if you auto-draft
I'm gonna be honest I've seen auto-draft
teams win it's completely okay so we're
still thinking of August 22nd looks like
we're gonna do the sleeper app so why
don't you download that check it out get
comfortable with it and then we'll have
more details going forward but 1164 97
team 97 conferences we literally have
about tripled what we did last year the
33% is the [ __ ] it is awesome
while you're at it after you listen to
the interview hit up darius butler on
social media and let him know and at the
end of the podcast we've
without probably the worst freestyles of
our entire lives so if you want to make
fun of us
please go ahead we're gonna have some
gambling podcast next week to start
betting on preseason football which is
absurd I'm hoping to have some
information to you guys soon about
people that are gonna be joining the
podcast during the regular season but
guys it's about two weeks away and as
you're hearing this right now we're
getting ready for a Hall of Fame weekend
we're getting ready for the first
preseason game football is practically
upon us so here is a little
advertisement and then our conversation
with former quarterback
Darius Butler you might be 16 now I'm
telling you you wouldn't be the first
man maybe at the end ok Michael Vick
said the same [ __ ] then he said next
time you hear mr. Darius Butler man from
Florida then became a part of the
Connecticut mafia that all got drafted
into the NFL just a few years the
Patriots then the Panthers and a nice
little five-year stint with the six
sorry count I have I literally look
through your career and your timing and
everywhere is very interesting you saw
some shop yeah so what I'm we're just
gonna get right into it
I didn't realize so you go to the
Patriots 2009 yep same draft classes
Julian Edelman yep also Tom Brady coming
off an ACL tear yep
so you get it to New England and this
dude is rebuilding himself yeah he had
long hair and news that's still majestic
oh he's a guy we're gonna talk about all
this but then you go to the Panthers yep
first year of Cam Newton yep then you go
to the Colts first year of Angela oh you
saw all of the like the rebirth of Brady
the beginning of
the beginning of key you've seen oh [ __ ]
now [ __ ]
three completely different guys and
kraut dogs all competitors are killers
but three completely different ways
about their business um I saw you on get
up today we're gonna get back to all
that stuff in a second how is post
career media stuff going it's cool just
getting um I kind of try it took like a
year just kind of off just chill
deserved a family home yeah and then I
direct just kind of started getting busy
kind of figuring out what I want to get
into talking about to trying to
broadcast bootcamp that went well and
now that was a few months ago now I was
just like you know what let's just get
it started give it a shot is the media
what you thought it was gonna be like is
it different how does it compare to like
what you thought as a player um I always
have respect for the media because I
knew it was a tough job especially like
the local beat writers they always
needed you know same guy same locker
exactly and you got to deal with guys
after you know shitty games that's a
good game so it was tough so annoying
question exactly exactly so I always had
little side combos with them but uh so
it's a lot in them playing as long as I
did I got to see a lot of my teammates
transition you know I played over
and--most and I saw him on Monday night
yeah Matt Hasselbeck it just saw God's
transition so Steve Smith you know so
these guys kind of gave me a little
tidbits here in there so it's work
though like those induction meetings I
mean it's just like a meeting go before
you go into a game it's a game and then
you have the post meeting and getting
yelled at like you get yelled at by your
coach and I like that I think I would
love of media was like that um like that
I want to be like what the hell just
happened but I was like good show
everybody
yeah I agree I try to build something
special definitely when can we start in
the beginning though get drafted by the
patriot yeah Belichick calls you up and
you're going holy crap yeah second round
pick Bill Belichick mr. secondary I
always hear people's interactions with
Belichick how different is it when
you're a member of the secondary though
because I feel like that's his pride and
joy it's uh is that he's so hands-on and
see more hands-on with that group than
any other group um when I was there it
really depends on how a staff is I think
she know if he has a guy that you know
it's a you know eight year god we had a
first year debe coach when I was a Josh
Boyer so he was definitely a lot more
hands-on with us and he had me Pat Chung
we were both second round picks we
brought in Shawn Springs lead body so we
had some old guys Brandon Meriweather so
we had guys kind of all over the place
in their career and dumb so he was real
hands on the backs but I mean that was
you know at that time looking back on it
I would appreciate it a lot more as the
fourth fifth year guy home and coming
out because he has his ways and it's
like Bill's way or no way right so you
know I'm coming in as a high draft pick
filling myself right and you know I make
a play he be like nah like you didn't do
it the way I coached you to it you know
so that was different for me and um kind
of hard got in that doghouse and never
got out and what are some things that
you've looked back on with age and go oh
it makes sense now that would be yeah
that experience you have been there just
how they go about doing business and you
it can translate into coz if I was a lot
of different way your old kid yeah I'd
be like and I hear I hear Lane Johnson
talking right now about how they don't
have fun and and I I see all these
veterans that go there that try to do
one more year and then like after two
practices yeah it's different and it has
to be a shock to the system but you
coming out of college you don't even
know what the NFL everyone's telling you
it's different
and you're getting the most different
place out of any place at any but yeah
so I'm sure you had moments in that
first year where you're like man [ __ ]
this yeah the first the first year
honestly was more of a breeze because
the front of rookie year just happens it
just happens so fast you combine into
the tribe I you know we're starting and
um so I was kind of thrown in the fire
played a lot my rookie year so let's go
to the playoffs yeah going into the
second year and we had to lock out going
into my second year so I had to like you
know meet up with practicing they don't
707s and Boston College and [ __ ] like
that so we missed some of the offseason
and got to the season and
you know kind of struggle early out of
the gate and then kind of just kind of
confidence got shaky right and then she
just went downhill got bench kind of
found my way back and then going through
that third year that's when they release
me
Carolina had some crazy [ __ ] going to
Carolina off the field I just kind of
that season was kind of a world for you
personally
yeah my daughter and my daughter she had
open-heart surgery like as a two-month
oh you know I mean like literally I
found out on the phone walking off the
practice field went straight to the
airport this is probably week three or
four in the season Wow
so that was that was that was crazy but
I mean every literally every every
player has their own when you please I
just watch all or nothing Panthers and
there was a scene where Devin Funchess I
think it was a family member that had
gotten shot and killed and he did not
tell the coach or anybody for like two
three weeks oh yeah what's wrong with
you yeah he's like and he just broke
down it all came out it was it was
Rivera right yeah remember was he
someone that like understood what was
going on with you I'm sure some coach is
like Michael Bennett just came out about
Belichick and I guess he had family
issues he was like get out of here go
see them yeah like I never know if
coaches are if they get it because I
hear stories where they're also like
they're different wanted here it's
different depending and you got to think
of God like Bill I mean he's not worried
about his job security
Robert Vera's rookie years and head
coach oh wow
so it with a rookie quarterback you know
this is my first shooter he was trying
to figure out you know if I was gonna be
somebody he was keep he will keep around
and you know that happened and but at
that point you know it's things that's
big in a football like literary football
was for the first time probably in my
life since the teenager like it was the
last thing on my mind you know what I
mean so obviously that's gonna affect
your performance gonna affect how you
practice you know to me so but um you
know it's part of it you know I end up
getting old with Indiana
I mean Indianapolis and uh you know I
had a good six-year run there and I have
fun was that was that Patriots Panthers
- Colts was that kind of a blur that
whole thing to you he sounds like so
much stuff was changed it was just so
many um so many ups and downs but does
it mean it's about how you react don't
know you know getting release from the
Patriots after my second year
yeah what it bill likes ad so I actually
went to bill kind of into my third year
training camp and because I kind of
still east in September yeah
so I saw shot so I saw the kind of
writing on the wall how practicing going
how things were going
you know what you know I'm calling my
agent at the time it was rosin house and
my truth man like you know I need to get
out of here man he traded released
something I gotta get out of here he's
like bro
don't go to build just figure it out
like we gotta figure this thing out and
I'm like I know when I dare try to
figure and just things weren't going
right so I went to Bill we got a
conversation he kind of you know broke
me up got me back going my alright then
literally we get all the way into game
week important part of that for me you
go to Bill yeah you nervous not at that
point cuz I mean you've been arrived
been around 2 years so he is open but
obviously say what's the deal I don't
just have a man-to-man talk lay I did
want a fresh start at this point I know
I can play I started confidence myself
maybe I just need a fresh start and he's
like you know no you know so just build
one of those guy like he puts the
clicker down and he like turns to you
like what's yeah he's a lot more
personable than he comes off yeah he
does he doesn't really like to do it
it's just extra you know extra noise on
there serious about you guys so much but
everybody else here yeah doesn't care
but the timing of the release was still
you know obviously it bothered me
because once you get released in
September the cuts have already been
made from training camp guys has been
picked up on waivers all time same party
thrown names
exactly exactly it's why this Mike
Daniels release was like really
surprised it was but at least they did
it at the beginning training camps now
you know he's you know he's going to
Detroit and he'll be fit he'll be ready
for week one you know so did you get
claimed by Carolina I got claimed
immediately I got claimed by a bunch of
teams Carolina got the rights to me
because they had the worst record the
first yeah they were two and fourteen or
some [ __ ] like that year before so and
we're going to Carolina and it was going
decent I was coming in playing like
sub-packages um and then the thing
happened my daughter knows just you know
what I mean and right and then once I
got back you know
once you have that losing season shit's
gonna change they drafted Josh Norman
some other guys and then [ __ ] just
changed and I end up getting picked up
by Indianapolis like week probably four
into the season cuz I got hey just had
the first yeah I had an injury
settlement when I got released from the
Panthers I had a concussion in the last
preseason game so it was it was like a
good three week period I'm like
literally on the street like you know
two three years ago I'm a second-round
pick now I'm on the street it's like
damn like now I ain't going out like
this when I get back on like like where
like for me when I when I hit that
moment where I'm either exhausted or
[ __ ] didn't go my way I always feel like
I'm on the couch and I'm sitting there
and I'm gonna mmm not today yeah what
was your I am not going out like that
moment uh-huh
I mean really just being home and like
kind of F because this was kind of after
this was kind of beginning of the
concussion like everybody was afraid of
the concussions I was like this you know
oh [ __ ] like he got a concussion like
I'm like damn like I'm gonna be scared
off for that I mean cut twice in the
last two years like so it was kind of a
uncertain I was uncertain you know when
I got released by the Patriots even
though I got released in September I'm
like you know somebody look claim you
know my agents like you know you'll be
good you know you'll land on your feet
but this time it was different in that
first week goes by second weeks like
okay third week is like damn and
literally I come in on Greeks and
brought me in his office and he was like
look man like if you don't work out this
time you might end up in Canada like
straight up you tell me like cuz at the
time and they brought me invite a was
hurt
they had Justin King he was hurt I think
drop I was injured and um so I was just
like you know what I'm gonna just give
it a I'm gonna go out my way though if
I'm gonna go out of my way absolutely my
first practicing up picked off flub look
a couple of times I got a start and
Thursday Night Football and had to pick
slumbers recovery and us and you look
back that's and cry yeah yeah it's it's
cool like I also think to what I try to
explain to people about professional
athletes they're not just putting on for
themselves mm-hmm they're not just
for their families their communities
yeah their school like I see you went on
get up today and Yukons like former
UConn what is on there and so there's
this thing that goes in your head when
you're facing like calamity like that
where you're like all these
[ __ ] are looking at me yeah
they remove them there but they're also
they're gonna be asking me annoying
question this isn't go right they're
gonna be sad they're gonna be
disappointed in me yeah I'm sure there
was probably a part of you that was like
this went from me being like everyone's
dream so now me being everyone's example
of see what happens when you don't take
advantage of things yeah like it flips
so quickly yeah and you're sitting there
and you're like [ __ ] that like I'm not
gonna be like that yeah and it's it's
like I don't even know how to describe
but it's scary it's stressful it's just
uncertain this is just that level
uncertain you know and then you just
saying like you you feeling like you
know [ __ ] I know who I am like I know
what I can bring to the table it's just
by having that right opportunity and I
was fortunate enough a lot of guys don't
get that third opportunity if I was
Draper I was drafted in the sixth round
I mean I got in that second or third
that one you know what I mean so it's
it's I think sometimes it's a burden if
a GM takes a guy too high and I'm just
like I think Jabril peppers going in the
first round yeah it's like a lot of
pressure on them at the same point dudes
gonna get like three or four more
opportunities because he was Corey
Coleman just keep keep getting
opportunities keep getting chances but
on and sometimes it works out for sure
hey word BAE yep where he hits that
second stage of his career and he's
better than he ever was early in his
career but he gets the opportunity cuz
it was a top ten pet exactly but when
Tom Brady came in with the long hair
what was what was it like cuz he had
already won a few Super Bowl oh yeah Tom
Brady what was it like is the rookie to
come in and see that guy it was wild man
cuz you go up first as a rookie you
report early and then I think the
quarterback show up a couple days later
I mean couple days before even the other
vets so on every time you know you'll
make a player somebody because hey you
know go make that play with 12 started
volume says Lucy
here yes okay with 12 in mind you this
is Randy Moss Wes Welker these guys
coming into camp too so it's like okay
yeah so once we once he got there
actually one of the first training camp
practices I picked them off in like my
local newspaper sun-sentinel like wrote
up an article like there is Butler picks
off Tom Brady in practice because
they're throwing Randy Moss I was so
hype about that and it's what I'm like
when you it's like you meet these guys
you know you you've seen them win so
many games you steady Bruce you see
Randy Vince wolf or Richard Seymour you
saw these legends and it's like wow you
had that wild moment and then like two
days later you're like okay these are my
coworkers now like these are my these
are my teammates like you know any kind
of goes away but what was it that
because I just saw an interview with I
think it's Devin Bush went to the
Steelers yeah and they said South
Florida cute in the rookie camp he was
talking a lot but they said in training
came we haven't heard you that much yeah
and I'm sure it's like what you're
talking about where you're the man when
it's the draft picks and we're the top
guy but when the rest of the team comes
in you fall in the line yeah what why do
you serve but when did it go from other
my teammates when did you feel accepted
it probably wasn't rookie hazing or
anything like that yeah
was it like one of them coming up to you
and and asking a question how does that
work it depends on the locker room it
depends on the vets cuz um you can have
certain locker rooms that um you come in
and guys may feel threatened by you
being drafted so high you know so you're
the guys the older guys are your meeting
room might not really accept you so is
it really depends on a locker room in
the culture so coming into that like I'm
coming into that culture like they bring
you right now obviously you got to pay
your dues you got to do to get ups in
your fight so I've heard of hey tell em
you're signing but yeah you know what I
mean but like they treat you with
respect your chin man you're not doing a
crazy [ __ ] you know what I mean so that
was that was that was that's the best
thing about it but as a rookie
especially back then you come in I don't
care where you draft your senior not
hurt like you just do your job and I
feel like that size you ever see a
rookie coming and try to be heard yes
and I felt like as I got older
it's so much because it's annoying man I
think social media had a lot to do with
it like guys just come in so much more
entitled now you know what I mean come
in you know a hundred thousand followers
or this or that you know worried about
your brand and now you know you're
trying to go viral some [ __ ] like that
and a lot of the older guys don't really
take you know know you already take
water that so you can get kind of put
and you know not treat it like what's an
example of someone coming in with just
too much sauce man you not to say names
no just coming in just you know meeting
started at eight o'clock like you need
to be in there like 755 and your seat
like yeah this guy may walk in at 7:58
you know what it [ __ ] show some
sunflower seeds but as a rookie have you
guys seen in the seat you know have your
playbook out you know so but like guys
there's no coming and cool you know but
you're Louie which it is you're that
like probably just to you know just you
bro we know you got it just come in do
your job go watching I loved watching
when rookies have to buy like 800 pounds
of candy yeah and all that stuff
Jonathan Avram the safety for the
Raiders is the podcast favorite player
in the draft huh he was just the first
guy had on from the rookie class I said
canary Shinji reott my Mississippi State
and all these articles are coming out
right now that Vaughn tez is like his
big bro uh-huh and he I am I'm like kind
of experiencing what it's like to be a
rookie through him talk to him a lot now
and he's like sharing these stories
about being like oh man I they can't
shut me the [ __ ] out there we go because
he's just that all the time there's a
story that came out that Jon Gruden had
to move rooms because Abram was coming
over too much to talk to him about
football too much wow I love that some
good [ __ ] because I'm sure when a rookie
came into Indy and they're like like
when Andrew Luck came in yeah I'm sure
all of you were like this is perfect
was actually every [ __ ] to you I came
in when you got there I bet you he was
the perfect perfect perfect ey the same
way yeah and he goes button luck you
know you know I make an interception or
he'll make a play on me he immediately
he wants to have a conversation you know
what
see what you know how did he get open on
that you know what were you thinking
what was it you know and we had those
conversations sure at one point you're
like man could look he's so nice like
you can it just rubs off for you so like
you'd pick him off he be like greater
severity but she got me out way what did
you see there like you know he wants to
know how it happened but it's always
good you're always learning and Tom
Brady thought picky black that should I
ask
I'm coming right back at you so he's a
little bit more Jordan where like if you
talked trash he's gonna take Evan to the
next slide sure lucky a good lucky black
all right good job buddy and his hair
you maybe think your [ __ ] you don't come
back at you have you ever seen him get
angry and I don't mean like angry at
himself like have you ever seen him show
ego so ego no no I mean I'm sure he
probably lays any guys and like I should
talk but he does he doesn't try to show
guys but uh you know your stories about
obviously in meeting rooms and a
quarterback should take command it's a
time and a place for you yeah I don't
want to call them call the goddamn
embarrassing but um you know you in a
meeting room a get your [ __ ] done you
know your say circus with the rookies
but I mean that's like you know you just
gotta do that you gotta get rookie [ __ ]
so compare Luck's rookie year to cams
rookie here
oh man and just like okay cuz I they
both there's a lot of similarities they
both went number one
both had extremely high expectations
they both have rookie head coaches yeah
damn what will be it was tougher for cam
because of the personalities that he had
to deal with as a Smith Steve Smith he
had Jeremy Shockey Wow
he had DeAngelo Williams now but he was
a great teammate but just got different
guys like that you know those are not
very very strong they're different
completely different and obviously cam
is a huge personality you know he came
in was like yeah exactly so he coming in
as a rookie it's tough to deal with that
now look he comes in you know you got
Reggie Wayne cool cool
ttyl who was he came as a rookie with
him Coby Fleener was when his guys came
as a rookie Vic ballot was a rookie who
ended up being you know the guy who
carried him out the bottommost Vic
battler Mississippi State also I think
yeah I think so yeah so um it was
different it was different ball game and
I mean you just had in in a comparison
Jeremy Shockey and coach later exactly
Vic Ballard and DeAngelo Williams and
like Stephen resume
I've always wondered that about Steve
because did Steve kind of take cam under
his wing a little bit or it wasn't like
I'm a vet and I'm trying to win a Super
Bowl and I need you to get the speed
really quickly it was no like baby
stepping with Steve it's like give me
the damn ball I want the ball here I
don't want to do that this is what I'm
doing like even Jeremy Shockey is like
throw me the damn ball you know so it
was no he got he had to get it up and do
it it fast so you ever talked you to
Steve Smith and practice it Steve Smith
may depend on you didn't know what you
were gonna get with him really he didn't
know like one day you know Wednesday you
Jam him up or something here play you
know good [ __ ] you know and then the
next day you Jam him up he's like kind
of like [ __ ] hands off me and try to
block you you know five seconds after
day all right so it was it was a I just
had to keep a had early on like a cloud
already plating against him in a game
before so that was good so you know he
kind of had kind of earned his respect
in that sense so we were teammates but
you kind of the first time the first
impressions everything so if somebody
tries you the first time however it goes
that time that's was gonna deal with so
the first time it was like it was a it
was a quick understanding cool cool as
hell from then on that figured it out
yeah cool one other thing I saw the All
or Nothing is they're getting Dante
Jackson ready on that Thursday night
against the Steelers which is when the
Carolina sees got a check it's all amaz
okay it's not as good as the years past
if I was going to be honest huh like
they had an Arizona Cardinals one which
was like when they went to the playoffs
was David Johnson's rookie year that
would be a loser sarens was like amazing
yeah this year I was just like a lot of
showing me football that I've already
seen okay but that Pittsburgh game Don
Jackson got moved to the number one
corner and he was on a B and I thought
it was really cool was I think it was
Mike Adams and like another safety /
corner Adams pops was like do not talk
to Antonio Brown and Dante at this point
if you remember last year had like four
interceptions very early was getting a
lot of like Defensive Rookie of the Year
be us and all that stuff and they kept
saying if you say like nice things to
Antonio Brown you're dead like if you go
hey man nice route he owns you and they
were it it sounded like the Jordan rules
yeah where you do not talk to this guy
did you have that like is that an
experience or their way at world would
it be no it was a cool way be I was
literally with them when he got drafted
like he had the same agent at the time
and he was kind of going through you
were in the same class no no I was I was
already drafted I had the same same
agent he went 61 six rounds so this is
probably after I don't know maybe day
two or three and the guy who worked for
Aging gives me a call because you know
South Florida I'm down there yeah I am
me somewhere and I think he was at the W
somewhere
hey teapot man what you doing man my all
I'm sure I'm doing this a man coming
through I got one of my guys like he
going through it right now like it just
highlight him so I coming there you know
to be chopping up and guys are getting
drafted its quarterback gets drafted
before him he's like paid oh yeah so I'm
like yeah like man look man when you get
on just get in there do your thing and
at this point I didn't know much about
Antonio Brown and watch them at Central
Michigan right but I'm just you're a
yeah yeah I'm just like man whatever it
don't matter you get drafted or if you
don't get reading once you get in there
you show up business so to see his
career take off the way it did it's
crazy but um one experience I would I
can think about is Megatron like I used
to talk I played against him in college
too and I talk every time you talk [ __ ]
to like nothing no just stylist and it's
like that's just kind of scary or
anything it sounds like when you're when
you go to like London and there's those
guards and you're just today yeah yeah
getting nothing and I saw him brother
one day Antonio Brown during is yeah
yeah and you're probably like
good luck in Pittsburgh man were you
there when he got drafted no oh yeah
when you got dressed like that mommy got
dressed so um damn did I stay the moment
the call I'm not sure about that
actually so you were the wise guy that
gave him confidence
yeah Oh Jimmy yeah I'm not saying you
don't but you know just gave him
encouraging words and I remember um even
uh
cuz Emmanuel Sanders got drafted earlier
in the drafting he might have went third
or third or fourth round or somebody
maybe third round he got drafting up
taking a B I think in the sixth round
but um all those guys into a ball don't
know my shares later where you were like
that's that same same [ __ ] yep yeah I
follow because that obviously after you
know you have that yeah you had that
meet when I'm always following them any
time we play he's always killed us too
every time we might be matched up with
him Andy murders what's really
interesting is when I started with like
when Instagram stories was big and
snapchat snapchat I think exploded with
DJ Khaled and the Antonio Brown was
always around eg and then I started
following on Instagram stories and all
that and I would see his workouts every
day and I remember the rehab where I'd
see him like doing finger climbing on
stairs and he would be strengthening his
finger yeah and I didn't really follow a
lot of other NFL players so I assumed
everyone is how all NFL players workout
no I now follow in an ornament amount of
NFL players he's the only one that I see
every day multiple times a day doing the
most years or commemorations to workouts
I've ever seen and then I had Trent
Brown here and he's like Trent's like I
was just wrapping up my first one in
Antonio starting his third workout of
the day is it does it all come back from
being slighted in the draft does it all
come right at chip on the shoulder the
same chip and he's always play even when
um you know everybody kind of went up in
arms when they pay him before Mike
Wallace it was like well you know I got
early so obviously they saw it before we
did but um he that his work ethic is
insane it's a very few guys that I've
seen that worked like a B and and he
passes it on you know he's working with
young kids he wants a Nike tour going on
but so I respect that I respect
shame or anything the the ben
roethlisberger Antonio Brown Mike Tomlin
trio mm-hmm
what do you think broke that in comments
about about being and night you know the
53:52 guys and then kind of been like
you don't do that and I don't know what
happened it had to be said yeah it was a
bit was a Jim who said that like Ben's
different than everybody exactly now why
even just some Sheldon watching him at
training camp the other day and I see
like you know throwing passes and
everybody been just out there without a
helmet on it's probably not a big deal
to about that so it's not a big deal to
prior to everything but to me as a
player I'm like I couldn't even imagine
like Brady out there you know throwing
about and not having him you know what I
mean like he's what's funny is is to me
at always I always go back to like Babe
Ruth mm-hmm where it's like he was
amazing and he eats six hot dogs in the
third inning yeah they're like wow and
we kind of celebrate that a little bit
we celebrate when a guy wears a hat and
goes I'll turn it on for the game yeah I
Simpson always tell me this story about
warrants at were like he'd you know he'd
be feeling whatever he I would get two
sacks though and it's like man you're
not even caring yeah yeah and when
you're that good nobody can say [ __ ] but
when you're not winning it's a huge
issue because all I ever hear from you
guys it's about accountability it's
about accountability but I'm is we're
all we're all in this together and
obviously you're getting paid twenty
million has gotten about getting paid
five hundred thousand but we are we only
as strong as our weakest link and that's
that's the difference and coaching out
he's won two championships so obviously
the [ __ ] he's doing in the field is
working it's a thousand ways to skin a
cat but I mean just from the optics
scene I have friends that have
accomplished a lot in their life but
they could have accomplished more if
they were focused you know what I'm
actually been it's sometimes people say
this about Shaq how many championships
were they have won yeah if he had Kobe's
mentality I don't ever want to take away
because everyone's journey is their
journey yeah
Shaq enemy and Ben's gonna have to but I
always wonder you know if Ben was eating
like Tom Brady and and working out like
Cam Newton and all
music that's tough for me it's tough
it's because that's very fan thing -
yeah it's tough because who's to say if
a guy works like that in five years in
you say man this is too much you know
right I've made them of money I'm ready
- I'm ready I'm ready to champion I'm
like I'm done you know I've had enough
I'm burnt out in a sense you know so
some people gotta have fun with it like
cam his rookie early when I was there he
had a lot of fun with you a lot more fun
with him Brady your luck did on the
field but he's still when the game time
came when practice came he was competing
he was playing so I'm you see you see
the Patriots you know dynasty you saw
when the Seahawks were on everyone oh
they were doing it completely
differently you know what I mean I got a
basketball hoop in the meeting room
yes Marsha I'm not going to meetings
issues so it's different ways to do it
but but I what I've realized is every
time a team wins the Super Bowl mm-hmm
the media we reverse engineering and we
say that's how you make us I do it yep
so when the Patriots win it's the
patriot way yeah
don't talk business when the Eagles want
it it was so you need to have an owner
that allows us players to be vocal and
then you need to focus on like tight
ends and and read-option and whatever
like if Shaun McVeigh would have won the
Superbowl that would've been enumerated
still we may have hired six like we joke
about it but like a very low level Shaun
McVeigh may have even gotten more of a
look definitely but it's a copycat
league it's how it works sometimes I
went on your Twitter and I saw a few
things you had one matp making some
moves up there in Detroit Matt patrician
I was blown away
that Mike Daniels came out and said he's
a genius because what I realized is this
is an in division foe that watched your
defense twice a year and left there and
said I'm gonna play for that guy which
carries a lot of weight yeah did you
play it all with Patricia oh yeah my uh
matp was what was he Maggie what was he
he was a lot it's so tough because so
many guys didn't have titles so you know
it'd be two guys calling the defense
other players he's not a D coordinated
sure he was a linebacker school he was
probably on the other side of the line
when you were at the Colts yep
what is what is the league's perception
of Matt Patricia because the media is
kind of like let's see if this Bella
check number two can make it may the
thing about Bella checks way in the
patriot way it works but let's not kid
ourselves Tom Brady being as great as he
is helps that work a lot now you have
those two things you got a guy like Tom
Brady
I want a defensive minded coach gonna
keep the defense in line and keep you
got a mate you got to manage men you got
a management it's hard so I said weird
dynamic when you're a head coach in the
league and you're making you know five
million dollars a year and your three
best players are averaging you know 16
17 a year so it's like you still have to
earn their respect like like a Popovich
Tim Duncan type relationship you know I
mean so that that resonates throughout
the team and a quick story my rookie
year this was a training camp you come
into it so after every practice after
every game we have low lights and very
you know Belichick puts the low lights
up from the practice or the game regarde
we could beat a team literally 59 zero
we go find the one plan we'll find the
three plays and [ __ ] love so he comes in
there he's like you know yeah I think
somebody had went and ran like a corner
out and Brady missed him in practice
he's like man you know what we'll be
able to win a couple games this year if
we got a quarterback that can hit a
[ __ ] guy when he's wide open so I'm
like damn he calling out time like that
and the team's I went to after that
you're not calling out your best player
like the coaches aren't doing that but
everybody's held to the same standard do
your job [ __ ] like this Tricia came up
through that came up today and you could
do that but you you gotta win early yeah
you gotta win early because you if you
lose those [ __ ] you lose that locker
room
she can go silence room I'm getting more
and more intrigued by Detroit making
moves man thank you because I started
excited but I loved their D I think
Darius I love Darius slay yeah I think
that they have a lot of good pieces I
just
it's a figure out the NFC North because
I could pick any of those two I can make
an argument for any of those teams I
like the beer is that it if I like the
Packers
you like those I'm not gonna lie I have
some gambling predictions coming up of
Packer
yes and the one thing that I started to
realize as I was looking through is I
was looking at turnovers because there
are a few things the NFL that typically
regress to the mean so come back to
normal if he if you got a ton of
takeaways last year that's probably not
happening again yeah it just it happens
every year this like the Jacksonville
Jaguars two years ago and then the next
year it's just not gonna happen if
you're very injured one year typically
that comes back or if you're really
healthy you're probably gonna get more
injured and I was I was looking at the
Bears their schedule is the I think one
of the top three hardest changes from
last year to this year okay and then
also they were one of the top teams and
takeaways last year at 12 and you don't
think you don't think that that stays or
did I thought Jacksonville's defense
last year was going to be the first
defense that goes back to back like that
and they fell apart but see it's the
thing that a lot of people don't realize
we're about to get into your coach
Jacksonville office suck legislature for
networks without the worst Bordeaux's in
figure and that doesn't just hurt in
points that hurts when when you're a
defense you go to satellite hockey
you're gonna just miss and three players
there it's a punt ready put right in
that defense is running back going
you're not gonna perform the same apps
now Chicago they got some weapons over
there they're missing one thing and you
can help me with this they lost Vic
Fangio you know in my mind got Chuck
Pagano
and so I have had Colts fans hit me up
and they have said that people are very
excited about Chuck Pagano as if you
look at the defense with the Colts
there's Colts fan our personnel compared
to what chuck has to work with now you
got Khalil Mack Eddie Jackson Akeem
Hicks I know it was a kid a drafted out
of Georgia to linebacker
College like you got rock ones yeah you
got some dogs over there and that's what
that's kind of what he had in Baltimore
and that's why I got the head coaching
gig in the first place he told me
personnel itself multiple times I can't
wait to be a fun coordinator again his
head coaches it's just
you gotta worry about it I mean he's
like I'm trying to worry about what
milhollin
what meals were eating at the front
hotel what we're doing here widest want
a coach I just want to talk defense sex
blitz his schemes so he's excited he's
back he obviously has a chip his first
time being a coordinator since its
Baltimore he went straight to head coach
a gig well you're clearly very confident
oh I can't wait I can't wait to see you
Wow what's other Kalina Floyd many guys
my guys Eddie Goldman Khalil Mac
Jonathan Bullard a real Kwanzaa they
need Trevathan who i love letter Lloyd
Kyle fuller they trade they get they
lose Adrian a most they get ha Clinton
dicks
Amukamara Buster screen I just think
this is every defense that's been like a
top five it typically regresses the next
year and it's not because the talent
it's I just when you're implementing a
new scheme even if it's a guy that you
love yeah I think it's a transition but
I'm betting against the Bears this year
and it gives us yes it's one of the
teams that I will be betting against
okay just because I need to get away
drone it well I'm I will do okay because
the thing that I always realize when I
pick teams is most people pick the same
12 teams that made the playoffs last
year good things will be good the Bears
will be good and the cops see I'm
picking the Rams a regresses you either
one of my team is to to regress I think
so - yeah I'm gonna I just what you know
how hard it is to sustain success very
well very we see things like the
Patriots and we think that can be
attained and I'm just telling you that I
don't think it can be there like the
only team I think is truly an outlier
everywhere else
it averages six new teams in the
playoffs every year so some teams have
to come out yeah and I'm looking at I
don't know if the Rams are gonna make
the playoffs Todd Gurley scares me a
little bit that scares me a lot I don't
know what he's hiding over here I don't
know what's going on over I don't think
he's right I mean I hope he's right I
hope it was just some that he's dealt
with and come back but the the main
reason that I'm betting against the Rams
is the interior of their offensive line
is has taken like a combined five
it snaps it's like Austin they lost
Roger Saffold they lost haven't they
lost a few other guys weren't sooner
then I'll tell you exactly he's up there
with his left tackle he's now like what
37 it's got to be like 50 but their
interior offensive line is left guard
Joseph Noteboom Brian Allen at center
and then Ostend life we talked about a
lot last year the Chicago Bears push
that offensive line around golf couldn't
do anything
Eagles push that offensive line around
couldn't do anything I'm just looking at
the tee there's a there are holes hatred
scheming him up but as many times said
it is still Shaun McVeigh and I'd yeah
but I mean guy guys get to kind of
figure him out too you know when you
come in you can kind of take the lead
you can kind of catch the league off
guard you've seen it happen with Greg
Rome with Casa McVeigh sound different
sounds but see what you see I've seen
things come and go I've seen but he's a
smart man I watched Chip Kelly go ten
and six in year one yeah but I don't
Vegas Chip Kelly I think he's better
he's better he manages the men better
guys didn't like Chip Kelly personally
who are you really high on this year um
I think San Fran was surprised a lot of
people that's we agree I think Russell I
got faith in Russell Wilson I always do
yes obviously lost some pieces but Bobby
wag is still over there how about your
how about your Colts so Hanako see if
I'd be disappointed they don't make it
to championship Sunday and it's just
it's the best old line by far that
Andrew Luck his head
you got tyo and he should be healthy
going into this year we got Funches
another red zone target hopefully he
takes that leap that Ebron did when he
came over from Detroit
you got Jack Doyle back healthy you know
you got Matt kind of running back by
committee and then the defense I lon
Tomsk
I think Marlon Mac can be a 1 oh
absolutely and I think not him Hines if
used correctly could be like that
connection JC oh he's so athletic
but he had the defense - who was there
DC now
Eber fluffs yeah he's a ball they love
him they love him mother I got a chance
to go down there and kind of see talk to
him talk to the coaches talk to a lot of
the players you know you got Kenny Moore
over here dear you say you show a ton of
love to Kenny Moore and I talked a lot
about Kenny more recently because of the
things he's done this officer yeah
paying for the funeral also saving that
dog and when Roger that
but Kenny Moore I saw was listed in one
tweet as they were talking about great
slot corners and you made sure to get a
retweet in there to support Kenny Moore
over sure but I don't think a lot of
people know about him on the field a lot
of people know by me it's a smaller
market and and he's not even slot corner
he started wanting a starting job over
you know Quincy Wilson who was a hot
pick Nate who was a draft pick cuz Kenny
Moore came over Thunder at the free
agent he was one of those guys he I
think I cut by New England actually and
he came in and instantly you know just
asking questions just latching on just
doing everything right and you just know
kind of like okay he'll he'll make his
way I didn't know he was gonna be what
he is now this quick cuz he you know
even though I did my expectations but
disguising him I'm glad they paid him
they took cuz yeah that's the best thing
about building a coach like you pay the
guys who doing the right [ __ ] they took
care of him Chris took care of him so
that's one of those things where if a
certain guy gets a contract the whole
Locker the locker room sees then it's
not okay because they didn't have to pay
one of those guys that you saw get paid
that it kind of uplifted the locker room
you know what it wasn't a lot of that
when I was with the regime that was
there and like cuz I felt like drill
free makes real Freeman was a guy that I
felt like I got what some other guys did
I fell in love with his big names from
other teams and they pay him a bunch of
money I come in and they don't even fit
in you know I mean we had a lot of that
going as a potent and Chris's Chris
Bailey's doing the opposite he's doing
obviously they got a ton of money to
spend you got a ton of money but you're
paying peer to zero you know a guy who
does the thing on and off the field
right away you draft a guy like Darius
Leonard in his second round
yeah took everybody you know by storm
you know Quinton Elsa and that was a
kind of easy pick you know and it was
you know we he was more than what we
expected really wasn't an easy pick
because if you remember ro Quan Smith
was still on the board Terrell Tremaine
Edmonds was still on the board
and the the Catholic Colts defense was
like thirty second that year before and
so everybody was like they need to get
the middle linebacker quit Nelson we
look at it now and we go like he was
definitely up there but I think I
remember the Colts were the the six pick
in that draft they started off at three
and then they traded down yes the Jets
if they stated three Wow
choke now that was that was the pick
that everybody simply choked and so I
mean they everybody would see no defense
yeah and they went in there and they
went offense and then they went offense
again in the second round and now the
next eight years of that franchise are
gonna be completely different
yeah and that's best that's what I'm
saying he made the right move and yes
going back to six a chance to meet him
yeah oh yeah yeah I play for him for you
what's yeah it's great dude great dude
he gets it he was a coach before yeah
you know he gets it with the guys he
shoots he shoots you straight he
straight with the team Frank Wright is
the same way that's the song time you
said they should extreme yeah have you
been with coaches that don't ton of them
what is who Vinny omits the words like
don't as a player you you don't want
coaches playing mind games you don't
it's just like what we see in the media
my coach you get there oh yeah we're
really high on this guy yeah we love
women of it in the next day just trade
it or some [ __ ] you know oh yeah he's
not so what happened what was one
example with you ah man hold on
um one example with me probably be uh
had a coaching in Carolina and they were
kind of kind of started writing on the
wall there and there we go oh yeah you
know you don't grade through this little
boy you're gonna go out here in this
fourth preseason game to four preseason
game okay but it's a lot of it is a lot
of it you got to read between your lines
alone I wanted to pull you aside go
listen you need to ball out in this for
your asses out of here
shoot a straight that's that's that goes
a lot longer way but like I was back to
that pig he needed to draft that because
what luck was Luck was banged up
throwing tennis balls yeah he was banged
so you had to sure up that old line and
I finally got him all aligned did he go
and win another old Lyman's he went
Braylon edwards before dares Leonard I
think they had two second-round picks
yeah I had a bunch of pixel when they
trade it back to six
yeah because Braden Smith was a
second-round pick and then Darius
Leonard so the first three picks were
quit Nelson now they're starting right
tackle Braden Smith and Darius Leonard
yeah that's I always go through this one
Eagles draft in like oh one or Oh to
where they went
Lito Shepard Sheldon Brown Michael Lewis
Brian Westbrook and it was like our
starting secondary and Brian Westbrook
and then in like the fifth or sixth they
also got like a Brent Celek or C like
that yeah and it's when the Saints had
one a few years ago where they got
chimera in the fourth Ram chick at the
end of the first round is another
starting guard in the beginning they got
Marcus Lattimore like they got like they
had on like four guys yeah completely
change as a French it does if they pan
out obviously and your guy who you're
betting on the Packers I feel like they
did they do a rod a huge disservice like
they don't draft him any first-round
talent that you can throw the ball to it
you can handle ball off there's always a
defensive guy an old lineman I think the
only offensive draft pick they had and
probably less and let but I'm not
counting this year yeah and think about
it but it's probably tackles I can't
think of a steal Ryan LeMond 2010
Davante Adams was a second one second
runner we can't stay yeah I really
thought speaking of the Packers they had
that pick around like 11 12 or 13 and
the two names I kept thinking was Noah
fan more and hawk and Hawkins Dean or
whatever Huckabee's I'm getting tight in
a or you know one of those wide
receivers I wanted Hollywood to go there
I want a Hollywood Brown and go to
Packers so what do you think it was this
kid all decided by him and Miles Boykin
apparently are playing really well in
Baltimore yeah apparently that's the
story excited about him am excited I'm
excited to see what Baltimore Braves did
say was excited about how they're [ __ ]
Murray
they just gotta put some around him and
I I was doing a little bit of reading on
him last night so apparently this is
what Larry Fitzgerald said on Sunday
spoke very young I've never seen a
quarterback come in so quickly and be
able to command on offense from day one
he's checking different play
sliding the line different protections
getting us into screens when blitzer
coming his understanding of the offense
is craziness B I had his offensive
lineman just to puon recently he was
saying he just gets it this is the
offense that Kliff Kingsbury was
building for him and Texas Tech the
other reason I get excited was the teams
in his division Seattle San Francisco
and the Rams San Francisco da stuff in
the last year those three teams with the
thousands of snaps they face and only
faced four wide receivers forty three
times that's about to be the Cardinals
offense what you sound like for like for
wha this is what Kings Barry's gonna do
Wow okay it's gonna be Larry and it's
gonna be one of the rookie wide
receivers the big ones like Akeem ever
and the inside is gonna be Christian
Kirk and then it might be that Isabella
kid but that's the offense with David
Johnson oh the receiver run it was 10
yeah and and then it Skyler on the read
option and you ain't beatin him to the
edge yeah rookie quarterbacks always
have success running the ball Lamar ran
great Cam Newton ran great Josh Allen
ran great like they always can do well
Carson Wentz ran Andrew Luck ran yeah
I'm just looking at the Cardinals I
don't think their defense is good but
they might be in like shootouts City and
I'm excited for calimary I'm excited to
see him place he's a winner he's all
those things that Larry's saying like
being able to call your own protection
yes just like that as a rookie and it's
probably honestly it sounds crazy it was
probably easier for him cuz this is
probably the first time in his life that
he's just focusing on football he's been
a two-sport athlete he was the first
athlete ever draft the first round
baseball and football so now it's just
football so he's probably walking apart
and all them studies protections now I'm
not worried about this that Arthur so I
make some exciting sex I'm just excited
for NFL football oh my god you're guided
watch a damn preseason game we are gonna
have a guest next week I just can't tell
you guys crack is coming back
crack is like this right incredible
gambler he I guess he's got his own app
I I don't think he was born the eighties
but crack was big in the eighties but he
apparently a little birdie told me that
he's incredible at betting preseason
games well and that to me as a new level
that's that something to it I never the
Zeke situation what is your initial gut
I mean they're not they're not making a
run without him that that team is built
to run
he makes deck a lot better oh he makes
him re a lot better honestly because you
got it you got to put eight in the box
to stop him especially with that old
line with Frederick's coming back Oh um
but uh you got a he they got the rights
to him for like another three or four
years with the franchise got two years
left on his deal you got to pay Dec
first you got it I feel like you got to
pay your quarterback as early as
possible that's gonna be your guy you
got a paper early for you have Pam forty
million they have four guys that I think
need to get paid DAC Z is this in order
this is not in order
DAC Zeke Amari and Byron Jones Byron
Jones guy and I'm telling them right now
UConn but yet if they overlook Byron
Jones the patrons will find a way to
make him the highest-paid quarter the
inside oh no he gave Gilley a lot of
money well by that time like two three
years on the road what I'm going to use
he have live Bari
what to want his rookie deal damn he's
coming up he's coming up yes coming up
and and if I was how would you rank
those four like you would put you gotta
go to a quarterback if he's your
quarterback he got a professor guy you
got a ping um and then Z Kumari and
Byron I go Zeke to him because Dallas
went far in the playoffs because their
defense last year defenses everyone is
[ __ ] talking about Amari Cooper and
I'm going know Marcus Lawrence and Byron
Jones like a Becker's those those would
be the best peer in the league probably
starting this year because like the
Carolina pair is over there that pairs
done the Tampa pair Levante David Kwan
um yeah so you wanna do like a KJ right
Bobby well yeah they did it one a lot of
they won a lot of games so um Anthony
bar Eric Kendricks so they're gonna
they're gonna try to keep those guys
together - yeah they got that in the
site yeah that's like three years in
this house man but um okay so DAC you go
deck Zeke I gotta go borrow you got to
go borrow it tomorrow it's I know that
am Ari has been a completely different
person in Dallas uh-huh
but I'm still worried you still worry
about him drops not mental Amari is
because what Jerry Jones did to Zeke is
a negotiation tactic for sure and I
don't know how a mari would react to it
Zeke went to Cabo yeah Zeke said I got
an agent I think that's absolutely but
here's the negotiation tactic that Jerry
Jones used Jerry Jones has always been
Zeke's number one fan yep Zeke gets in
trouble with the league I'll fight Roger
Goodell for you Zeke is doing issues in
the streets I can stand for Zeke's
character yeah but now it's money and
Jerry Jones says the point is you don't
have to have a champion a rushing
champion to win a Super Bowl
we are looking at putting Zeke's
contract in place you have to realize
the ultimate goal is to win the Super
Bowl
so you have to do things along with
having Zeke and other players to win a
Super Bowl
Jerry has always been Zeke everyone out
there doesn't like you that's great but
I have your back I have your back unique
and now that money is on the table he's
going I don't need you Zia I think if I
can win a Super Bowl without you he's
been through that for he was Zeke I've
seen this story before of course in 1993
we got a Hall of Famer Troy Aikman y'all
a favor Michael Irvin we could still got
the best so lining Lea we don't need him
yeah start owing to yes Zeke Zeke would
be in that building about what happened
to kam chancellor
you remember the Bengals tore up the
Seahawks defense they would pay that guy
it's what happened to the referees I
told Trent Williams
let Eric flowers play two games and then
watch them drop an extra 15 guaranteed
on the first year but I look at Zeke and
it's I don't know how what Amar'e would
react to that that's what I'm yeah Zeke
is sort of like whatever whose eggs
admit he's been through a lot of [ __ ]
already or he's been through a lot of
[ __ ] so he's trying to get ahead of the
because he knows the same thing we
talked about those guys are in line to
be passed and I don't know where Taiwan
Smith is in his deal but I'm sure he's
somewhere down Tyron Smith wow he's good
pay up nine years 97 million it's like
you have a tackle or $10 a year
brilliant oh you know I I'm very curious
about that I thought Jerry Jones doing
that it was an interesting move but I
look at Zeke and runningbacks need to
get paid and I and I I'll say this a
million times I know that running backs
are replaceable I know that they can do
this it sucks because it's not hit so
much they get hit so much and their
careers are smaller and they're showing
right there's a lot of analytics that
are talking about you play action is
successful without even having to run
the ball now so it's like changing
people's minds but Melvin Gordon runs
differently and Zeke really runs
differently because I've seen this
offense with other running backs yeah
I've seen it without for Morris getting
a hundred yards Zeke would have gotten
200 yards different speed is incredible
at the goal line
yeah the way he could knife in I seek is
also just he takes the soul out of it
he's a face in the passing game yes
which is slept on like I grew those were
you running back by committee and all
these things but this it's exceptions to
every rule and exception I read it I
read a whole thread on this the other
day about running backs are devalued but
running backs that can receive may
actually be more valuable than like
tight ends Stephanie
so those cámaras the sake wands the
referees they are they can they're not
even really called running back yeah you
know how we have like defensive end
linebackers and people call them edge we
need to come up with a new name for the
and not just a receiving running
got Le'Veon girlie a lot of missus it's
it's a very few very good running backs
that you just turn out of hand the ball
off to now that's kind of oh but when he
gets in December he gets nose play oh
wow man you got to be able to run that
ball have to you got to be able to run
that ball you got to better stop to run
you ever have a situation where they
asked you to get around the line of
scrimmage and someone turned the corner
and you went damn I have to take this
[ __ ] one-on-one oh man yeah yeah
it was the first one that made you in
LaDainian Tomlinson man and the Jets
I caught him late in his career still a
beast so I admitted he had met him in
the hole hum smack me ran me over and
you know you know it's part of you you
gonna get God at some point the next
stand away room Mike was to be a Hall of
Fame strength coach you got like six
foot burns in the Cowboys and Patriots
goodbye he comes up to me in the weight
room like hey you know where the
equipment guy is able to um you know
handle that I'm like well he's like what
everybody get like those cleat marks out
of your jersey so but that was that was
kind of one of my welcome to NFL you
know Michael Turner when he was in
Atlanta you think they'll say quantize
Mike return is probably his legs are
probably bigger Michael Turner was the
original like muscle Hammond how low did
he get cuz he was holy he was like MJ
low man wins a football he was already
down there and it was like because most
guys especially for a DB you want to
tell you want to hit the league you
wanna try to grab but [ __ ] yeah tree
trunks I read they hit him up top and
take much his just so it was tough I
mean you come across a lot of those guys
Maurice jones-drew is gonna be one of
those guys that we look back and I don't
think we're gonna be able to fully
appreciate how good he was
yeah I think he's gonna be forgotten in
time yeah and it sucks agree he was
because he wasn't even he wasn't the
best running back in their franchise
history yeah Fred Taylor I know I Freddy
T so let's tell you're a Florida guy to
sow your seed to use a piece yeah Freddy
T is the Roy Jones jr. of the NFL of he
has he has so much respect and he always
did it his way you know they kind of
look alike a little yeah yeah I love
that comparison
drop that on if you talk to anybody I
played against him with them or anybody
around the league like Freddie T's when
it comes to respect like he's up there
he's up there Frank Gore's of the world
and Adrian James is like he spoke in
that same you ranked your top five
corners oh yeah
you went zaevion Howard five yep Byron
Jones for Jalen Ramsey three Casey
Heyward two Stephon Gilmore one yeah the
only question I have is why is Casey
ahead of Jalen for you those are those
are interchangeable okay depending on
the the matchup that we can go gentlemen
to you see I can't I can't take your
side is bachi
and I get it that's what you're not
gonna ask you but what is it what is the
matchup that you would put Casey over
jail in there hmm lets you know one in
two pins see it's hard because if you
just like this is what Pat piece
suspended so patty would definitely be
in where would he was he'll be up there
you'd be top three I don't know where
but when you watch guys that what is
tuft it was tough to leave Chris Harris
out was tough to lay out there heroes if
he's healthy so many guys that you get
when he's in these positions but Casey's
been quietly like a dominant like a
dominant player and I can't think of a
certain match right now but are they
running like do they run zone are they
in that because it's there it's that
like old Seattle scheme right when are
in you know Jacksonville well and also
the Chargers because they have the old
Gus what's this Bradley yeah yeah so how
do you deal with the whole zone versus
man if you're if you're a guy who it
depends man because there's different
ways to do it like Richard Sherman like
you just get a lot of [ __ ] back he's
like oh he can't be a top ranked when he
plays one side of the field and he plays
cover three right but [ __ ] he did it
great and I mean like you try throw
Depot he's gonna get picked up he was
crazy turnover numbers every year every
year so that's what your defensive
coordinators actually to do that's
what's helping your team get to a Super
Bowl
by all means now your Pappy and you say
hey I'm gonna put you on the number one
guy in the Safety's going the other side
of Phil every week that brings a lot of
value to the team - if I'm building a
team
I will prefer to Pat pee right in that
situation because I want you guys take
the case he hit well Ramsay ok see it
was the case yeah we can match up to now
yeah you got Desmond King who's a who's
a dog out there you got you got you got
a lot of players on it I love I love the
Desmond Kings the Eddie Jackson's the
Patrick Young's I love the like Shawn we
got drafted together man going strong
dudes that just like [ __ ] people up in
the middle of the field yeah I can also
play corner but they can also like rush
the past do a lot cover guys they can
blitz they can uh you know cover tiny
his cover receivers played a deep middle
you know the Eric widows of the world
like like their ball is in a slept on
the darkest join the Marquis Joyner yeah
was he Oakland Raiders hey man our guy
Jonathan Avery aren't together so is a
room starting now I don't I think right
now they're looking at like the three
and there I think they're kind of trying
to figure it out with reps and stuff
okay I would bet that Abraham's gonna
start he's gonna be on the field for
sure have a package at least it may even
throw in her back in new cool in certain
package you did transition the safety
yeah and I feel like that's like a thing
that we do with corners now yeah what
it's that transition like it's tough man
tough Miz but it is easier to go from
corner nickel to safety because you're
kind of yeah it's kind of how would send
out Charles Woodson today because you
know corners the corner is a simplest
position to know like game plan wise
like I know my assignment go yes
starters position to actually play
physically play you know on the defense
side about in my opinion and you go to
nickel mentally you got it you got to
know where the linebackers are sometimes
you got another stunts up front you may
have a gap you got to fit you got to
know what your corner you got to talk to
your corners about yourself so much more
fear of getting blindsided exact you get
a crack but just so much you have to
deal with and you have to study so much
more film and be ready so when you make
that - when I make that transition to
safety being able to communicate with
more guys pre-snap I was great at that
but it's
those ankles getting used to taking
angles we're getting used to now of
running back is coming up scot-free huh
up the B gap and it's like you know I'm
the one that got a savings a touchdown
so that's tough as a nickel as a corner
you're usually the fun of them back to a
linebacker that's haulin ass or so you
come back so it's different tackling in
space you know a little quick receivers
now you got a tech watchful tight in
like what's a Sunday you know Sunday for
the last few years has been in the
kitchen over there and I set up like I
said it like six TVs I do one on red
zone just so I don't miss anything and
then I try and watch four or five and I
have like sheets where I like take notes
of like ham any big because if I was
yeah you're talking about it I see I
wasn't talking about it so yeah honestly
I didn't watch a lot of football into
I'm sure late October once the games
really start counting they're my okay
let me - let me see who's gonna be the
playoffs who's Lunas who's doing that
but yeah it was I really didn't watch it
um and then kind of wants that part to
see that's when I started to miss it
like [ __ ] it's divisional is these guys
are doing this so that's when you start
to miss it but you know so this year
I'll be especially if I'm in the media
and talking about our definitely locked
and I got to get [ __ ] DIRECTV you got
to get the package or go so you can
watch eight games at a time because
right now I got the red zone and it's
like you get updates but it's not the
same it's not this yeah it's not the
same you got to figure something out
because I I get excited about the non
scoring place not exactly you just see
the touched a exactly you know I'm
trying to see that like really big third
and seven that might not get picked up
or so yeah that all right so your your
sleeper teams this year
you like the Niners I like the Niners
any other sleeper teams mm-hmm I mean
the Jags will do better but I don't I
don't see them winning at Division you
think you think the Browns can win the
north
not this year okay I don't think they
can't I don't think they will though I
think I think Pittsburgh's do ones that
still I still think is big big big are
you got a chip initial man no a B no
bill now you know now he's gonna
fortunately he has guys who can step up
to the role I'm a little concerned about
how durable Connor will be this year
that's why you saw I'm kind of breaking
down last year because it's different
when you're taking you take no shots
especially in that division division and
the Browns do have a defense that it's
my office that put up points I just
don't see them
Freddie kitchens is my biggest question
mark there and um you know how that
office makes everybody happy and then a
team that made the playoffs last year
that you do you think the rams are gonna
miss the playoffs or i-stop wouldn't be
I wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if
they missed it mmm you got a division
like I look at the divisions like okay
what divisions could send two teams NFC
North I think the NFC South and then
maybe Eagles and Cowboys yeah especially
if Zeke is back in that building early
so it'll be it'll be it'll be tough I
mean it's a crapshoot it'll be tough why
not take shots it'll be tough and then
do the Patriots win the AFC East
literally as I fill it out it's like
going feel like the number one in my
bracket and beer
oh yeah Saiyans gonna get past that 16
exactly exactly the same I mean it'll be
it'll be some game it would be some good
games would uh I am think the Dolphins
always blame - I'm high on the build-up
yeah I haven't like officially put at
the stone yeah I don't I don't trust
John Salley at all
at all I am I think Shawn McDermott has
shown to be one the best offensive
coordinators in NFL I think they
completely rebuilt that offensive line I
need to see what this rookie running
back is Henderson and see if he's like
because they're saying in cam right now
that he's like they don't might not even
need LeSean McCoy
whoa they finally get a they switched
from all really big receivers like the
Kelvin Benjamin's and stuff the foster
kids showed out last year they go and
they get cold Beasley underneath and
they get John Brown or smoke yeah he
needs to be accurate you gotta be
accurate the little guys I just don't
trust just a big shot McDonald I don't
trust them at the defense I'm not
worried about a defense at all
guys on the defensive side of the ball
just don't trust that offense I know I'm
also rooting for the Jets to just to
finish second finish I got a lot of
weapons that CJ Mosely which isn't
talked about a lot Le'Veon now used to
be like MVP Le'Veon Bell will be he'll
be in a conversation for best running
back and all those people that were like
why are you sitting out yeah a year off
like I couldn't imagine how fresh you
started running to conditioning to us
are there any issues with being that
fresh it could be but I know I
personally know how he works out I know
where he works out yeah down in Davie
burritos and he worked his ass off so
it's not like a guy who you know I think
is just you know if it work is a soften
in the studio
yes you know some other stuff but I'm
looking forward you got Sam Donna you
got um him a slot receiver Crowder
Crowder you got you guys got some
Anderson every year this year I'm
looking forward to AMC's but I mean come
on I'm sorry all right Nick let me get
that beautiful music and maybe maybe 808
dB
okay do serum okay yeah check it quick
fo lose hope kick back with left cold
hey [ __ ] I might go [ __ ] it
let me give football stop okay thing I
can take it to the top hey fellas check
running the team you can't miss them and
everybody knows you just can't dissuade
Tom Brady Travis back he throws in
practice and everybody knows that you
just can't act this it's too real it's
too authentic and I don't have a word
[Music]
Darius Jay Butler Twitter Instagram yeah
follow me man follow this man a few
weeks the NFL is okay we can't wait
after you guys holla holla holla I hope
you guys got into the fantasy league
over a thousand we'll have more up
days later but for D Butler I'm left go
holla holla at you later man that was my
worst
[Music]